Guys, let's put this all together. Let's do this from start to finish. And what I want
you to do, I want you to hop over to the perfect prospecting script. And I'm going to pull
it up on my screen right now. Guys, this is the perfect prospecting script. And at the
top, I'm just going to go through this really, really briefly so we can put this all together.
At the top, I've kind of just put this as a way to just mentally see how this works.
So the way that this was explained to me when I first got into sales, when they were teaching
me like, okay, here's the steps to a perfect approach. Here's the steps to a perfect door
approach or a perfect cold call. They described it, the managers, and I had really, really good
trainers, people that really knew their stuff. So I love sharing this stuff, but it's the sizzle
and the steak. So the sizzle is you call them, you grab their attention, you break the ice.
The steak is, hey, here's the step. Here's exactly what I'm doing, why I'm calling, the deal,
and the transition. The sizzle is grabbing their attention. So just maybe as more of a visual,
think of it as a sizzle and a steak, just like you would when you're grilling a steak. So you
got that sizzle to grab their attention. Then you got the actual, the thick of it, the steak.
And that's the way that I think about it. So I just listed here, the sizzle is to grab the
attention, break the ice, get them to ask in their head, what the hell is this guy doing?
You're getting their attention. And then the steak is the steps. Who you are, what you're doing,
what's in it for them, what's in it for you, and transition. This is one step combined,
that's the deal, but I just separated it out. So guys, the funny thing is, or not the funny thing,
but the ironic part is, this doesn't look like much. This has every step that we just covered.
The who you are, the what you're doing, the deal, and the transition all built in. So
if you guys choose, and you need to, for these first couple calls, guys, read this verbatim.
It doesn't matter. It does not matter. And if you read this verbatim, you actually will get
people on the hook. No shit. You will get people on the hook. That's how good this is. It is deadly.
Now, once you master it and you can just start speaking like a normal human, plus say these
things, you're going to be dangerous. Let's just go through this. So again, as we talked about,
first thing you're going to do is, hey, Jack, this is Nick. Do you guys do ex service? Do you
guys do patios? And again, this is going to be a slight variation of what we talked about,
the same exact concept. Do you guys do patios? Cool. Or do you guys do patios here in Little Valley?
You can combine it. Great. And then they're going to respond. Okay, great. And do you cover
this area, which we talked about? So, hey, do you guys cover Little Valley? Do you guys cover
Henderson? Do you guys cover Summerlin? Do you guys cover Norcross? A suburb of whatever, wherever
that lead is at. Do you guys cover 84790? And they're going to respond. Cool or excellent.
Last, lastly, how far out are you guys? You can even make a joke. Can you guys actually do
something in 2022 or in 2023? Are we looking at like in a decade? I mean, this is getting crazy.
Oh yeah, yeah. No, we're a couple of months out, but we can get, we can take care of you. Okay,
cool. Okay. And so then, and you'll notice here, like I make, this is a little bit different than
what I explained, but it covers the exact same thing. And so I'm not actually going to reshoot
this. Okay. Because I want to prove a point here. It's about hitting the steps, not about having it
in the perfect order. It's about hitting the main point. So in this script, this is the script I've
been using forever. This is how I have it listed. Ironically, as I was teaching and training the
last few times I've done it, I put this at the end and I want to keep it this way because I want
to show you that it doesn't matter. You just need to hit the point. So in this script, it says we,
we, we can say, Hey, I've got this lady. I got Janet here. Janet here in Little Valley. She needs
tree service or she needs a tree removal. And I just wanted to make sure you could help them before
I wasted any of your time. Guys in the, in the last couple of videos, I mentioned this at the end.
It doesn't matter. Okay. This is just how the script is right now. Okay. And feel free to make
some tweaks to this. It fit this, fit this to your style, but realize it's just about hitting the
points. I just want to go over that. Okay. And then I put to which you will continue. And guys, I,
I left out what the business owner is going to say in return, but you can kind of just interpret
the business owner is going to say, you know, who the hell are you? What, whatever, right? Who's this
guy? Like, what are you doing? Et cetera. Oh, sorry. Like I said, my name's Nick and I have a
website and phone number here in blank city in St. George. That's getting a ton of, or getting three
to five concrete jobs every week. Notice how I said jobs, not leads. Very important to, to notice.
Okay. And then I put here I, and guys, again, you could read this verbatim. It will work. Okay.
I was planning on sending you a couple for free before I take any of your time,
but to be candid with you, I am looking to find a partner here in Austin to work on an ongoing basis
or just here in Austin. Okay. Doesn't need to be perfect. Okay. I want you guys to see that this
doesn't need to be perfect. Okay. Continuing. I noticed, and again, you can probably just guess,
Hey, I transition right there. I noticed you're already paying for Google ads. So I know you're
hungry to take on more work and figured since I already, since I already have to work, why not
just work with you directly? Guys, it's just a different order of what we already talked about.
Okay. Again, so, and then you can imagine the business was going to respond. So let me send
you this lady. Let me send you Janet real quick, maybe one or two more. And then all I ask in return
is a conversation in a couple of days. How does that sound? Is that cool? Same thing, right? Just
in a little bit different order. Okay. You open to that and then literally I put in here, that's it.
I'm going to bold this actually on, on, I'm going to bold this. That's it. That's all you need to say.
Okay. And I even said right here, that's it. Do not discuss, in fact, I'm going to put asterisks
by this. Do not discuss price. Do not tell them you were looking to do a flat fee contract, blah,
blah, blah. You will lose the deal. We talked about this at the beginning when I said, do not,
you're selling dinner. You're not selling marriage. Okay. If they ask repeatedly,
and this is one thing I want to point out. Okay. And one thing too, I want to just add into this is
we need to add transition. Okay. Let me grab. What's the best email and phone number to send leads to
explain. By the way, I'm doing this real time. So you let's, I don't even, I hope this isn't
even getting edited out. I want to keep this in. Okay. Explain the live transfer
and then pull back if necessary. Okay. There's a couple of things I want to add. Okay. Last
thing I want to mention on this, cause guys, that's it. There's nothing else to talk about.
If you need to read the damn script, read the damn script, this will work. This is like,
this is why I call it the perfect prospecting trip. Read this shit word for word. It'll work.
Read it word for word. It will work if you need to master it, learn it, put it in your brain,
and then say it as you would say it. And you're going to be a deadly human being. You're going
to be a savage salesperson. Okay. You're going to be hooking people freaking left and right. Like
you're using some illegal substance. Like they do out on the, on the lakes where you use corn,
or where you use like WD or DW, whatever that stuff 40, where you spray it on totally illegal,
but it works like a charm. That's going to be you. Okay. Last point is this. Okay.
If they ask repeatedly about price, which they can and sometimes will, I mentioned here,
and I said this at the beginning, just push it off till the end. Hey, look, I'm not actually
worried about that. I do all kinds of different deals. Like honestly, that's the, that's the
wrong question. We're putting the cart before the horse. Let me get you a couple of jobs
before we even get to that. Okay. And if they keep going to like, Oh, just give me a ballpark.
Here's my response. Okay. To be honest, I have, I have somebody right now that's paying me around
three to $400 per month. And I also have a company that's paying me $50,000 per month. So it's going
to be somewhere in there. No, but seriously, that's not that like we'll, we'll work something out.
Don't worry about that. Okay. And we're just, we're just kind of, we're just saying, Hey, look,
it's going to be, it's too hard to tell at this point. Stop asking that question. Okay. But if you
need to satisfy them, cause they keep asking, I like to use that. And that's true. Hey, I got
somebody paying three, $400 bucks and I got somebody paying me $50,000. I definitely can tell you
you're going to be way closer to the bottom than the top, but we have a huge range. It depends on
a couple of things, but I don't, I don't want to waste time on that until we can figure out if this
is even a good fit. Okay. And back into it, back into the process, right? That's what's cool about
having a process. You have your steps and your transition. And if you deviate and start asking
questions outside of that, you can answer it and come right back to where you were at. If you, if
they cut you off in the middle of explaining the deal, cool. Answer it. Come right back. Like I was
saying, I want to give you a couple of free leads. Let's talk in a couple of days. Why don't I just
give you the leads in exchange for, we work something out. I mean, I don't know about you,
but unless you have some kind of a romantic relationship with Google or Larry Page or
Sergey Brin, I don't like, I would love to work with someone local. And I'm sure you would too.
Okay. Just address it. But the point is, and I mentioned this at the first, don't sell marriage,
sell them. Okay. Guys, that's it. This is the script. This script has been working like a charm
for me for years and years and years. And yeah, I had a couple of tweaks. You guys just saw me real
time. Add a couple little tweaks. Okay. The important part is that we hit the steps necessary.
And just to recap who you, first of all, the sizzle, okay. Pattern interrupt who you are,
what you're doing, which is a damn good reason why you're calling. Okay. And I like to make sure
that you remember that the deal, what's in it for them, what's in it for you, stressing more on
what's in it for you and the transition and drop in a pullback when necessary. Guys, that's it.
Hook these people. Let's get them some leads and let's get one step closer to closing the deal.